all right what do you think of this UFC
card first of all just like in general
what a career for Nate I think that he
does go box now and then maybe he's
gonna wait and see what happens between
Silva and Jake and then take advantage
but here's the thing if Jake beats Silva
which is a [ __ ] tough fight yes it is
a really tough fight for him like so
much credit to him for actually taking
that fight because Silva is a striker
who actually has boxing fights on his
record boxing only Southpaw which could
line up okay for Jay because Jake's got
that big right hand
um but
I mean I mean that's a massive [ __ ]
Step Up in competition for Jake
but if he gets by Silva the thing is
nobody is going to be surprised if he
could get by Nate
because people most people would be like
well yeah Anderson Silva is a better
Striker than Nate Nate might be more
durable Nate's Jujitsu might be better
Nate might be able to like sustain more
punishment and then Tire you out and get
you at the end
but I don't think many people are going
to sit back and go Anderson Silva Nate
Diaz who is the better Striker but Jake
and Anderson aren't going to have any
build up
Nate and Jay oh yeah build up of the
[ __ ] decade like it'll be insane back
and forth conference here and there but
like Anderson's I don't think he's gonna
hype the fight as much as Nate will and
so to that regard yeah people would be
like yeah Anderson's a better Striker
technically yeah but the spectacle will
be bigger with Nate 100 agreed 100 yeah
I mean I'm looking for and I hope they
both get crazy [ __ ] money yeah like a
really interesting thing will be like
observes it bro Jesus yeah Nate deserves
it he has all these fans and you know
Nate's always going to be kind of like
the face even though he's like The
Lovable bad guy but um it would be
interesting to see what happens with
with Jake you said the interesting thing
with something I don't know forgot but
uh but yeah just I don't know I'm very
excited to see what's going on I mean he
wins so many interesting things with
this car this card he wins he ends up
fighting Tony Ferguson who in my opinion
should retire I think he's seeing better
days in the last five fights he's what
like oh and oh and five yeah and um but
he ends up finding Tony Ferguson and he
beat Tony Ferguson I mean the card gets
completely jumbled around you think it's
planned no not at all not at all really
I don't think it's fine I think that I
think what happened is that I'll be an
idiot and say yeah that's that's right I
know Dana White says oh you're an idiot
for thinking that but yeah no I could
see why people believe that because it's
such a weird change of events and also
worked out so much better
in my opinion I think the card is much
more interesting the way it played out
than the way it was scheduled yeah I
mean I also think comes out beats Nate
honestly I don't know I think comes up
Beats Nate definitely
um it would have been like one-sided
it sucks for Nate to go out like that
yeah he's like hey
let's just at the last moment give you
somebody that you could possibly be yeah
maybe I mean look Hamza
he's an easy person to I don't want to
say like support but believed it would
be Nate but the problem is that like
Nate fought he went five rounds with
Leon right taking big shots from Leon
Edwards Leon Edwards that's those same
kicks that landed on [ __ ] Usman yeah
yeah Diaz eight yeah for lunch walks
through hamzat in the last fight that
went three rounds were against Gilbert
burns gas the [ __ ] out looked exhausted
after the [ __ ] second round he's not
as disciplined as the other like yes
um or khabib yeah yeah well because he's
he's Swedish I wonder how much that
plays a role like not growing up in
Dagestan I wonder if it actually impacts
the way you approach the game I'm sure
even with like the same camp the same
training like he's got all these guys in
his Corner yeah I'm sure just like that
little thing Sweden is not hard yeah and
he did some cheap [ __ ] like Kevin
Holland goes and takes this fight which
is a far more dangerous fight for him
Kevin Hall has no wrestling background
whatsoever he's not the thing that he's
bad at is wrestling and he's fighting a
guy who who whose major skill is
wrestling right
goes up to fight him they go to do a
glove touch Holland goes and puts his
hand up for the glove side and then uh
Hamza
fakes the glove touch and then shoots
for him yeah
and then the rest of the fight is what
happens if I and it's up to Kevin
Holland to protect himself at all times
100 you know what I mean like but that
being said you talk all this [ __ ] I'm
gonna kill everybody I'm gonna Maul
everybody I'm gonna walk through
everybody it's like okay then do it the
right way yeah if you can kill everybody
you can do whatever you want in there
you don't gotta cheat
and it's not cheating but it's not the
most ethical way of doing it it feels
cheap it feels cheap yeah and you
probably could have got to him everybody
gets to him that's a good wrestler Kevin
will admit he's not a great wrestler
yeah so why'd he even do that who knows
but uh as far as like the fight card
getting like all switched around
my understanding was that I guess what
Dana White said is that hamzat was on
weight to make weight and I guess the
commission told him not to because maybe
they thought that he was losing a
dangerous amount of weight
except I saw and heard just through
Twitter that he was at a restaurant the
night before just like hanging eating
taking care of people for like six hours
before like he was just like posted up
who knows what I mean Nate was at a
concert the night before watching Tony
Ferguson footage if he was watching
fight footage there's there's video of
him at a concert watching fight footage
yeah it's amazing that's how he's gonna
film that show he was gonna say no no
but there's a video somewhere wait a
minute Nate was watching Ferguson
footage the night but this was after he
was announced he's gonna fight Ferguson
yeah yeah and another reason why I think
that they this was planned was because
it's like you train for your opponent
you train for your opponent's style so
it's like to just switch your opponent
at the last minute like everything that
you've been doing for the last few
months and now it's like oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna fight a completely different well
almost four people think about it
fighting different people so think about
it they knew beforehand well what how
did Nate finish uh Tony Ferguson
oh with the chocolate Guillotine choke
right and what is what what does a
wrestler do they shoot so that's
literally all he was practicing in Camp
he literally said to Rogan afterwards
he's like I didn't box one day in Camp
Wow all I did was a wrestling camp I
actually think that's why he came in a
little heavier like not only did he have
to make less weight I mean he was
fighting like 170 but I wonder if he's
like having more weight will be
beneficial to me because would be harder
for me to be tossed around by this guy
if I want to be light on my feet and I'm
moving and I'm shaking and I'm going to
be kicking I'm striking with somebody
then maybe it's better I'm a little
leaner but if I come in a little bit
heavier let me not get flipped exactly
oh that's interesting so and the fact he
threw him in that gate now he's nice at
Jiu Jitsu but still that's what they're
planning for the whole Camp is he's
gonna shoot I'm gonna get under that
neck crank night night and the fact that
that happened makes me go well what
would happen if Hamza shot on him you
shoot on a black belt like Nate who is
nice at Jiu Jitsu now it's time to dance
Jiu Jitsu starts where wrestling ends
yeah you know what I mean like wrestling
is getting some under the ground Jujitsu
is like oh we're on the ground let's
dance so I can't I can't exactly count
Nate out like
I don't know man Nate's also so
interested in me like because I forget
that he's good at the technical side of
martial arts yes you know what I mean
and really like honors martial arts yeah
because he doesn't seem like that guy in
any other fashion at all he's smoking
weed he's you'd see you think that this
guy would be like disrespectful and like
[ __ ] up and not care about it but
within the confines of martial arts
incredibly respected most people it
applies their whole life yeah I mean
like Rogan always talks about it it's
like yo I was like fighting kids and
doing whatever then I got into martial
arts and like it changed everything for
Nate it didn't seem like changed
everything stays right there stays
compartmentalized within martial arts
and then everything else is just [ __ ]
kid from Stockton yeah yeah and that's
why we love it yeah I guess right but
that's why I feel I feel he would have
taken the fight even if uh kamza came
overweight like oh yeah NATO type is
like yeah whatever he's a little heavy I
don't think it was his decision though I
thought it was Dana's decision to flip
if we're even if we're believing it
wasn't staged yeah it was Dana's
decision he can he can't do anything and
low-key if it was Dana's decision just
see that's fire of them because they're
already feeding
Nate an absolute animal in Hamza who has
a size advantage over him strength
advantage over him and a wrestling
advantage over and potentially a weight
Advantage if they went forward the fight
exactly and then you add that extra
weight which is crazy it's not like
we're talking about two or three pounds
we're talking about and then seven and a
half right
the fact they switch it up maybe is like
Hey listen we appreciate what Nate's
done we know that we've had a back and
forth that wasn't awesome but we're not
about to send them out of here on a guy
who'd missed weight by [ __ ] eight
pounds yeah that's disrespectful to a
guy that the fans absolutely love and
maybe it's brand protection it's like we
can't we can't let this happen
to a guy that the fans love final fight
our boy we built him up yeah yeah okay
and then you have a very like evenly
matched fight with Tony Ferguson and
another fan favorite and then they go at
it and everything's awesome yeah and I
thought it was really cool at the end of
it one this is like the most eloquent
I've seen Nate yeah so I wonder if
partially like when he talks at the
press conferences he's like super
calculated which slows down his speech
but then he's like kind of like joking
around he's like he's he's like teasing
and [ __ ] like that they ask him if he'd
ever do a Shoei he goes a Shoei
that's gross like he's like having fun
up there and he's like speaking quickly
usually there's like a little bit of
like a stutter he's kind of like slow
yeah and I wonder if this if he just
felt like no stress he felt Freedom he
felt release yeah it was great to see
him just talking man yeah it's
interesting now do you feel like Kevin
Holland feels [ __ ] over yo the thing
about Kevin is that he has that that
likability as well and I wonder if he
takes too many chances it's like at a
certain point we want to see you win we
don't want to see you get beat and he's
taken all these chances and he's
fighting these guys who have like
wrestling disciplines Derek Brunson is a
wrestler you know you can't wrestle let
the UFC pair you with guys that you can
have an even match up with as you get
better at wrestling and then climb the
ladder that's why him and Tony would
have been interesting to me yes and
that's why as soon as you put Hamza in
there it's like okay well [ __ ] but but
he wasn't gonna fight Tony Tony was
gonna fight the LI jingling or whatever
his name is oh Kevin Holland yeah Oh I
thought they just flipped up Oh I
thought it was just those two no no and
then Kevin Holland was gonna fight
um Daniel Rodriguez Daniel Rodriguez I
didn't realize they switched every one
of them every all three of those fights
yeah oh wow yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
they all oh I guess okay and d-rod is a
good fight for him because they're both
majority Strikers uh and I didn't
realize both those undercards were catch
weight yeah I guess that's a common but
yeah I didn't realize that yeah yeah
which that would have been a great fight
and that's what I want to see Kevin
Holland doing I want to see him fight a
really good guy like d-rod but maybe
outstrike him and continue to win Etc
what I don't want is him to just go up
against these wrestlers and just get
thrown in his [ __ ] back
and then game over every single time and
now you've got this guy who's got a
great personality he's incredibly
likable he's very funny but he's not
getting enough wins where the fans can
go I really want to see this yeah we do
not want to see you get beat in 40
seconds we love you we do not want to
see that yeah yeah
do you guys you guys have any interest
in the Canelo Triple G fight
what is this the fourth time third time
I don't even know when it is the boxing
has no ability to promote itself yeah
outside of the YouTubers and the
influencers regular boxers it's almost
impossible to promote their fights
Davis really has like he has a
stronghold on the streets we spoke about
this before right and it's like really
impressive because the streets does the
marketing for him he's not really out
there promoting the fights yeah but
everybody's like nah javonte's fighting
yeah he's the guy Adrian Broner had that
for a moment Floyd always had it and
another thing that's really interesting
about Floyd if you really like I don't
know if you guys remember Floyd would
always do parties after a fight where he
would just go to random say like North
Carolina I'll be at this place here
there's no way they could pay him enough
money where it's worth it for him to go
but I think that that was his like
reinvestment in the fan base oh
interesting yo I'm not leaving y'all I'm
in here with you guys
I'm part of this we're all partying
together exactly oh that's cool and I
really admired him because these guys
make 100 million dollars a fight there's
no way that his like forty thousand
dollars or whatever that you're gonna
pay him to show up is gonna be worth it
to him but he's like no this is how we
remind people this is how we feed the
base yeah yeah it's the 17th the 70s
this Saturday so this Saturday I'm just
like
September 17th I think is uh Mexican
Independence Day well this is Mexican
Independence weekend or something oh
really yeah but um yeah Triple G
I don't know man Triple G uh Canelo
I'm gonna put my money on Canelo because
Canelo has outpointed him in the past
but if he's still in that vegan [ __ ] and
maybe his confidence was a little low
from not winning yeah that last fight
and like getting handed yeah that last
fight
but did he he won the last two on points
no he won the last two uh a split
decision I believe oh really yeah yeah
but one of them at least was a bad
decision right some people say the first
one Triple G should have won yeah I
think the second one conventional wisdom
is the Canelo okay but then you know
with all these fights that are kind of
close but both of them are like super
technical they hit hard and it's just
it's really tricky I know I'll tell you
this if I was a betting man huh if I was
a betting man and I was going to put
money down
I would also miles I would also
you got it did I beat you oh sick okay
good I would also uh put my money with
betonline.ag the [ __ ] best
betting platform on the planet because
they're gonna uh match 50 of my initial
deposit bonus up to a thousand dollars
that means if I put a in a thousand
dollars I get 500 free dollars to go
gamble with probably put that [ __ ] on
Canelo because you know he's coming off
a loss he's probably back on the meat if
canelo's back on the meat guaranteed
favorite if he's still vegan
uh Joe Rogan believes it so yeah yeah he
told me that it makes a difference so I
believe him yeah I believe him
wholeheartedly I believe him
wholeheartedly so that's where I would
put my money bet online dot a g and
[ __ ] use that promo code
flagrant
use it
and get that [ __ ] okay what do y'all
think my fear is that it's not gonna be
a banger that's the only thing like yeah
you could put money on canelo's because
like technically he's like edged out the
last two yeah but I think to your point
why it's not bigger is that it's you
know they're like so equally you know I
guess like they're so competitive with
each other yeah yeah like they're just
gonna go to another Split Decision be
like oh the last fight was four years
ago right how old is Triple G yeah
because I feel like Canal is in his
prime I think the Triple G is probably
coming up on the 40. so I think you've
got to put your money I think canelo's
coming past his prime yeah but like he's
still a young boy relatively speaking
yes age-wise his last I think if he
didn't lose his last fight you would
think canelo's still 100 is probably
absolutely and his last fight he could
have just lost because he you know vegan
so I just don't see how you put you I
know nothing but I don't from a distance
I don't see how you put your money on
Triple G and age he lost the last fight
four years ago Canelo hasn't gotten that
much worse if he has so that means I'm
betting on Triple G then all right just
always go against whatever you guys did
not won the last one yeah all right fair
enough but what was the last one uh
uh doesn't remember it's UFC UFC
tomorrow and uh tomorrow yeah see yeah
Edwards you want big oh really you put
money down yeah Mom boy bet online match
that initial deposit bonus I'll stingy
like by 15 bucks